bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors un rassemblement est
organisé aujourd'hui en soutien à sa
traoré en marge de son procès pour
diffamation qu'attendez-vous de cette
mobilisation
cette mobilisation c'est pour rappeler
que la famille traoré n'est pas seul
dans ce combat depuis le début depuis
ces quatre années de combat
on essaye de criminaliser la famille
traoré
la preuve encore aujourd'hui avec ce
procès est ce qu'on trouve triste et
malheureux c'est de bois la justice
française
la politique française continue dans ce
mécanisme de criminalisation des
victimes donc cette mobilisation c'est
pour rappeler qu' il faut cesser
d'inverser les rôles
ce sont les trois gendarmes impliqués
dans la mort d'adama traoré qui
aujourd'hui normalement son sens est
propre et non à ça traoré
on va pouvoir citer leurs noms puisque
antenne site leur nom c'est tout
simplement rappelé que les deux
gendarmes sont censés protéger servir et
non tués
alors ce qu'on reproche un vous l'avez
dit ah ça traoré c'est d'avoir c'était
les noms des trois gendarmes qu'elle
estimait mise en cause dans la mort de
son frère
est-ce qu'elle n'a pas fauté à ça traoré
quand elle n'a agi de cette manière
alors que l'enquêté toujours en cours et
que le procès n'a pas encore rendu de
verdict finalement est ce une faute de
se poser la question est ce une faute de
le rendre public ce que la justice et la
politique français cherchent à
dissimuler
nous avons trois gendarmes qui ont
interpellé son frère qui avait le
pouvoir de maintenant et on se rend
compte qu'on coup il est mort entre
leurs mains la justice répond aux
interrogations de est un droit
tout à fait logique que la femme soit en
dignité de 2 alors on vous entend pas
très bien almamy kanouté on va essayer
poursuivre elle néanmoins cette
interview alors à sa traoré dénonce un
acharnement judiciaire contre sa famille
j'imagine que vous partagez cet avis oui
la famille trabelsi blachon judicieux
dans la sphère dans cette affaire on le
rappelle on a vu les expertises
médicales se contredire sur la
responsabilité des gendarmes dans le
décès d' adama traoré l'une d'elles
demandée par la famille elle met en
cause les forces de l'ordre ou est-ce
qu'on en est aujourd'hui de l'enquète
vous savez la justice aujourd'hui en
position tous les temps les éléments
toutes les expertises qui met en cause
le l'implication d'al à la méthode la
méthode est employée par les trois
gendarmes ont interpellé la dame traoré
qui a conduit à sa mort malheureusement
nous attendons que la justice ait
convoqué les justifie j'adore pas bon
pour les bondes rbo almamy kanouté merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes membre du comité
la vérité pour adama